would it be appropriate if I asked if we
could bow our heads for word of Prayer
the sanctuary God we welcome and invite
you into this place your house we thank
you for the spirit that dwells here we
also thank you God for all persons who
come seeking to expand their horizons
and seeking to learn more about what our
country is made up what makes us who we
are as a people and as country we pray
that our time here spent today will be
seen as an act of love as well as an act
of righteous indignation in the face of
injustice ins
and we pray that all persons here today
may feel your presence and be drawn
closer to you and Jesus name we pray